نشاطاته بنك مان ارتبطت مؤخرا بعمليات
تمويلا ام بضماناتنا وهميه مرتبطه اساسا
بالعملات المشفره وهو استنساخ لما حصل مع
الاستثمارات الوهميه التي كانت السبب في
انهيار السوق الرهن العقاري عام 2008
الفريق اليوم هو ان سوق العملات الرقميه
غير خاضع لاي تنظيما صار وهو ما يزيد من
قوه الصدمه بنك مان اقرب شركته الاخرى
المدى 10 مليار دولار لكن ماذا عن
الضمانات
لم تكن الا عملات اف تي التي اطلقتها افتي
اكس كل هذا لم يكن كافيا لتدمير الثروه
بنك الرصاصه الرحمه اطلقت من اشد منافسين
منصه بايننس
مدير المنصه اعلن التخلصه من عمله اف سي
اكس مشددا على عدم التسامحه مع من
يتلاعبون بسوق العملات الرقميه واحده في
اشاره لبنك مان
تصريحاته تشاود تسببت بحاله ذعر لدى
المتعاملين الذين قدموا طلبات السحب بلغت
قيمتها 5 مليار دولار وهو ما لم يستطع بنك
مان الالتزام به اعلان الافلاس بات امرا
حتنيا امتدى الاثر لسوق العملات المشفره
تراجعت باينس لتعلن تقديم خطه انقاذ
لمنافستها الاصغر في اكس لكن الامر اتعدى
قدره باينس على المساعدات فانسحبت وهنا
يؤكد الخبراء ان التخلص من منافسه بارز
يعد اهم من الاضرار التي قد تصيب السوق